einen schönen guten tag wir sind live
mit zdf heute leisten der erste größere
herbststurm dieses jahres zieht über
deutschland hinweg und gleich hat dieser
sturm massive auswirkungen wie schlimm
die sind wie die situation insgesamt
über deutschland ist und ob jetzt ignaz
oder hendrik daran schuld sind darüber
werden wir in den nächsten minuten reden
sie können uns ihre kommentare oder ihre
fragen in die kommentarspalten schreiben
oder an die adresse schicken die sie
jetzt gerade hier unten eingeblendet 10
mittlerweile gibt es deutliche
einschränkungen auch im bahnverkehr und
deshalb schalten wir direkt mal an den
kölner hauptbahnhof zu meinem kollegen
thomas münten hallo thomas
kannst du erst mal kannst du mich hören
okay das ist schon mal die erste
voraussetzung für unser gespräch thomas
sag mal wie es denn aktuell die lage wie
es der bahnverkehr im moment
eingeschränkt
im großen und ganzen muss man sagen
zumindest was den nordrhein westfalen
hier betrifft geht im bahnverkehr gar
nichts mehr wir haben uns mal hier die
seite aufgerufen bundesweit ist der
bahnverkehr durch das unwetter
beeinträchtigt quasi von nordrhein
westfalen über hannover rund um hamburg
s bahn berlin teilweise frankfurt oder
bis zur polnischen grenze also es gibt
an allen möglichen ecken und enden
einschränkungen besonders schlimm
betrifft das natürlich die leute die auf
den fernverkehr angewiesen sind wenn man
sich vorstellt dass hier zum beispiel
von köln/bonn richtung düsseldorf
hannover dortmund berlin das herz weil
da keine bäume im weg liegen aber alles
was von köln aus in richtung süden
unterwegs ist das pferd nicht das
bedeutet natürlich auch dass gar keine
züge aus dem süden bisher kommen und ich
sag mal das sorgt dann für das was man
hinter mir sieht lange schlangen an den
informationsständen und doch schon ja
wenn man sehr freundlich ausdrücken
möchte verärgerte und verwunderte
passagiere sind ja eben auch bei den
leuten die aus dem überfüllten zügen
kamen ganz andere worte gefragt
okay wir kriegen das auch hier von einem
user bestätigt wäre schreibt auf youtube
ich habe meine ausflugs pläne verworfen
und bin zu hause geblieben die züge
fuhren gegen 9 uhr hier gar nicht mehr
könntest du noch mal beschreiben wie die
situation am kölner hauptbahnhof ist
wird es mit sicherheit auch gelegenheit
mit einigen reisenden zu sprechen
also der schlimmste war jemand der aus
mainz kam der richtung norden wollte
bisher gekommen ist und dann blieb der
zug stehen er hatte aber heute morgen
als auch 9 uhr in den zug in mainz
gestiegen ist schon eine halbe stunde
gewartet weil es hieß der fernverkehr
soll eingestellt werden dann hat er
gesagt solche überhaupt losfahren hat
waren beamten da vor ort gefragt die
haben dann gesagt nee kein problem
klappt alles jetzt war er hier und hier
ist jetzt schluss hier sehr gestrandet
gerade hab mich jemand unmittelbar vor
der schalter angestupst er wollte mit
dem zug nach stuttgart fahren er war
inzwischen drei mal hier weil man ihm
immer wieder per app oder per internet
gesagt hat der zug nach stuttgart würde
jetzt wohl doch fahren kommt hier an was
fährt mich der zug nach stuttgart es ist
im moment so ein bisschen verwirrt
spielt auf der großen anzeigetafel
hinter mir steht nämlich der bahnverkehr
empfehle der fernverkehr ist komplett
gesperrt wenn man nach schaut stellt man
aber fest dass eben zum beispiel gerade
die züge ic nach berlin verspätet
falsche reihenfolge andere gleise aber
die fahren das heißt so richtig weiß
niemand ganz genau und augenscheinlich
auch die bahn nicht so ganz genau was
denn nun eigentlich noch geht oder was
nicht und das verärgert die leute es
gibt kaffee für die menschen die hier
warten kostenlos die beamten vor ort
bemühen sich wirklich auch in aller
freundlichkeit den leuten zu helfen den
leuten was zu erklären aber es hilft
natürlich in erster linie nur wenn der
zug fährt wenn der zug nicht wert ist
auch die schönste entschuldigung
irgendwann verbraucht gerade sind ja
auch in einigen bundesländern noch
abwehren was die lage mit sicherheit
nicht besser macht aber jetzt mal
abgesehen vom café welcher angebot hat
denn die bahn an die reisen denn die
jetzt vor ort gestrandet sind
es ist natürlich so dass man den sagt
sie dürfen mit jedem anderen zug fahren
wenn die denn wieder fahren das betrifft
vor allen dingen die leute die hier zum
beispiel super sparpreis ticket gebucht
haben die also die günstigen angebote
nutzen wollten den mann jetzt sagt ja
sie können
in den nächsten sieben tagen mit jedem
anderen zug fahren wenn sie wollen das
hilft den leuten nur meistens nicht und
ob es da dann das geld zurückgibt das
war auch für mich eben nicht
festzustellen ob man dann wirklich in
anspruch auf hat das geld
zurückzubekommen
ich würde vermuten ja aber man könnte
auch sagen es könnte sein dass der
höhere gewalt im spiel ist das lässt die
leute hier relativ ratlos zurück für die
die wahrscheinlich hier über nacht
stranden wird die bahn sich sicherlich
irgendwas einfallen lassen müssen aber
auch dazu haben wir bis jetzt keine
auskunft bekommen ich glaube dass die
bahn im moment darauf setzt das
sturmtief sie daraus ziehen dass die
strecken irgendwann im laufe des
nachmittags vielleicht wieder
freigeräumt werden können und dass man
dann vielleicht heute abend wieder in
eine art not zugverkehr zumindest
einsteigen kann nur auch das muss klar
sein die zügel wie diesen notverkehr
dann ausführen die stehen ja nicht da wo
sie eigentlich hin sollten die steigt
stehen ja da wo sie stecken geblieben
sind das heißt einen geregelten fahrplan
würde ich jetzt sagen wir mal bis
spätestens morgen mittag auf keinem da
würde ich nicht drauf setzen ich würde
jeden der irgendwie mit der bahn fährt
selbst wenn irgendwann der fernverkehr
wieder läuft raten erstmal genau zu
gucken was passiert mit meinem zug es
kann da zu verspätungen kommen die
erfahrung aus den letzten
unwetterschäden auch dann noch bis zu 23
stunden betragen und da muss man sich
genau überlegen was dann passiert wann
muss man wohl sein also es ist
ohne das böse zu meinen schon eine
ziemliche verwirrung und gerade hier im
kölner hauptbahnhof bei den menschen in
der schlange entlädt sich das ganz
ordentlich das bestätigt uns auch julia
schreiner die gerade im ic e 220 nach
amsterdam sitzt und uns zuschaut sie
schreibt seit vier stunden bewegt sich
gar nichts und bisher wissen wir nicht
ob und wann es weitergeht was gerade
schon so eine einschätzung abgegeben wie
es in den nächsten tagen weitergehen
könnte hat die bahn sich denn schon
irgendwie geäußert wann sie davon
ausgeht dass
verkehr wieder einigermaßen nach plan
läuft
noch gar nichts von offizieller seite
ist es uns bis zu uns hier nichts
vorgenommen das ist ja auch so was dass
die leute die hier stehen sagen wir als
kunden wir werden irgendwie gar nicht
bis zuletzt informiert was sich der
julia sagen kann ist das habe ich gerade
hier nochmal gegengecheckt dass die bahn
immer noch verkündet alle ics richtung
amsterdam und brüssel fallen heute
komplett aus ob sich das im laufe des
abends noch einmal ändert ich würde
nicht darauf hoffen bis der bahnverkehr
wieder richtig in normalen bahnen läuft
denke ich müssen wir davon ausgehen dass
wir wenigstens 24 stunden noch mit
verspätungen leben müssen und
was das für die leute bedeutet die jetzt
hinter mir und der schlange stehen und
mich weiter kommen hier irgendwie
übernachten müssen und natürlich auch
wichtige termine verpassen das muss die
waren dann irgendwie versuchen
abzufedern
also wir halten fest der ärger ist gross
ratlosigkeit ist da und wie es
weitergeht weiß im moment keiner vielen
dank thomas münten am hauptbahnhof in
köln und wie die lage generell in europa
danke und ja wie die lage generell in
deutschland im moment ist dass er
trainer severin nochmal für uns
zusammengefasst das schauen wir uns
jetzt an
dillingen im saarland hier hat sturmtief
märz in der nacht heftig gewütet ein
baum kippte auf dieses wohnhaus und riss
ein riesiges loch in den dachgiebel an
vielen orten in deutschland umgestürzte
bäume im harz bei braunlage kraft einer
auf dieses auto der schwerverletzte
fahrer wird ins krankenhaus gebracht es
ist der erste herbststurm des jahres das
ganze ausmaß zeigt sich vor allem in der
helligkeit wie hier in hamburg
[Musik]
liegt gegen eine hauswand auf der
rheinbrücke bei speyer in rheinland
pfalz wird der sturm einen lkw hänger um
die rheinbrücke blieb bis in den
vormittag mehrere stunden gesperrt auch
bei der bahn bundesweit einschränkungen
und verspätungen
in nordrhein westfalen wird am mittag
der fernverkehr vorübergehend
eingestellt voraussichtlich mit folgen
für das ganze bundesgebiet im kreis
breisgau hochschwarzwald müssen
bahnreisende aus diesem zug befreit
werden ein baum war auf die oberleitung
gefallen
das waren insgesamt so circa 80 personen
aufgeteilt auf zwei zugteilen da dass
sie einen bewaldete gebiet stattgefunden
hat das ereignis war das so dass man
erst mal zugänge zu dem zug das reich
nein du musst du mit motorsäge verletzt
wurde niemand für die bahngäste ging es
im schienenersatzverkehr weiter
und bei mir im studio ist zdf
meteorologin katja hallo katja senders
du dir zeit für uns nehmen konnten katja
was möchte den sturm jetzt heute
besonders es ist erst mal der erste
herbststurm und jetzt sind ja die bäume
noch geglaubt deswegen gibt es diese
großen schäden weil die bäume mit ihrem
laub eine große angriffsfläche dem wind
bieten deswegen gibt es die umgestürzten
bäume die großen äste die abgefallen
sind das besondere an diesem sturm ist
aber eigentlich dass ganz deutschland
betroffen es gibt höchstens einen
winzigen kleinen zipfel in südostbayern
der keine sturmböen keine orkanböen
abbekommen hat aber sonst hat das
wirklich fast ganz deutschland getroffen
ist ja schon losgegangen in der zweiten
nachthälfte das dann erst mal im
südwesten da gab es eben orkanböen wir
wissen müssen dazu bedenken dass orkan
ab 117 kilometer pro stunde gilt und wir
hatten in der mittelgebirgsregion sogar
bis zu 166 kilometer pro stunde jetzt
ganz aktuell gab es auch eine windböe in
dresden mit 119 kilometer pro stunde
also auch dort orkan und eben auch in
anderen größeren städten wie würzburg
wuppertal trier gab es orkanartige
sturmböen und das ist selten fürs
flachland normalerweise haben wir
kräftige windböen in den mittelgebirgen
an der küste da ist man das gewöhnt aber
so verbreitet über deutschland das ist
ungewiss obwohl es natürlich schon viel
schlimmere stürme schon viel schlimmere
orkane in deutschland gab und jetzt
reden viele von sturmtief ignatz die
rede ist aber auch von hendrik dagegen
die begriffe irgendwie gerade so
durcheinander vielleicht kannst du uns
darauf die ja dazu muss man wissen dass
die freie universität berlin diese namen
vergibt man kann ja wetterkarte werden
und es kommt aber darauf an auf welche
steve sie wie benennen jetzt haben sie
hendrik zuerst genannt das ist einfach
alphabetisch das nächste war dann ignaz
sie haben sich aber dann entschieden dem
hendrik noch so ein paar ableger tiefs
zu zu gönnen das waren dann hendrik ein
sentry 2 hendrik 3 deswegen glaube ich
dass wir eigentlich dieses sturmtief
hendrik 2 nennen müssten streng genommen
ist es aber vollkommen egal ob es einen
ignaz eis oder hendrik der deutsche
wetter dieses spricht von hendrik und
ignaz haben das ganze stuhrmann
angerichtet den ganzen sturm angerichtet
ist also völlig egal das ist eine sagen
wir mal eine einer sehr akademische
frage wie wir jetzt dieses sturmtief
nennen wollen okay nur dass man bescheid
weiß bis von dream rede ist hilfe uns
doch mal bitte vielleicht mit den
bezeichnungen da ist von orkanartigem
sturm tief die redet was er eben schon
diese stundenkilometer zahlen genannt ab
wann spricht man ja das ist auch wieder
eine relativ akademische frage also wir
sprechen von einem orkantief dann wenn
es einen kern druck von unter 9 155
hektopascal hat das hatte dieses
sturmtief noch nicht das waren also nur
unter 180 kilometer 980 hektopascal
und das bedeutet einfach wir müssen von
einem sturmtief reden nicht von einem
orkantief trotzdem kann in einem sturm
die wie eben ja schon genannt eine
orkanböe auftreten oder auch eine
orkanartige böen deswegen ist diese
begriffs bezeichnung etwas unscharf wir
im zdf sind eigentlich der meinung so
bald eine orkanböe auftritt können wir
eigentlich auch im ganz guten gewissen
von einem orkantief sprechen obwohl es
streng genommen dazu eben einen kern
druck braucht der besonders tiefes eben
unter 955 hektopascal
silke schreibt auf youtube in vielen
teilen der welt haben die auswirkungen
des klimawandels ob starkregen
dürreperioden stürme oder schon länger
tödliche konsequenzen
also wie würdest du diesen herbststurm
jetzt einordnen ist das relativ normal
für diese jahreszeit oder geht das
irgendwie in die richtung auswirkungen
gehen also zu dem zusammenhang
klimawandel stürme kann man
interessanterweise feststellen dass die
stürme jedenfalls bei uns in
mitteleuropa nicht direkt den
klimawandel zuzuschreiben sind man
stellt vielmehr fest dass es dekaden
gibt in denen die stürmer häufiger sind
zum beispiel in den 1990 er jahre da gab
es so eine dekade wo es viele stürme gab
und dann gab es auch wieder dekaden also
jahrzehnte in denen es weniger stürme
gab ein sturm wie dieser hier ist jetzt
relativ üblich nicht total
ungewöhnliches auch solche orkanböen auf
den mittelgebirgs gipfeln die kommen da
alle naslang mal vor zwanzig dreißig mal
auf dem brocken vielleicht im jahr das
was man da orkanböen hat also das ist
jetzt nicht so ihre ungewöhnlich und mit
dem klimawandel kann man diese stürme
bei uns nicht in verbindung bringen aber
wenn wir schon sturm und klimawandel in
verbindung bringen wollen dann können
wir das für die hurricanes also für die
tropischen wirbelstürme
da kann man sagen es wird wohl nicht
mehr tropische wirbelstürme geben aber
diejenigen die es gibt die werden größer
und verheerender und bleiben länger an
ort und stelle erinnere an den vor new
orleans hat ja kein großer sturm nur
dass wir einen unserer sie forderten zum
brocken hochjagen und diesmal hat es ihn
erwischt er steht in torfhaus am brocken
wie geht es dir beschreibt uns die lage
vor ort
omi g20 ganz gut aber ich stehe schon
seit acht uhr morgens und macht die eine
oder andere schallte wie soll ich sagen
unangenehm könnte man vielleicht die
situation beschreiben ist schon kalt und
ziemlich windig jetzt gerade wird es
nochmal ein bisschen regnerisch wieder
für zehn minuten pi mal daumen da kamen
durchaus auch mal die sonne durch heute
morgen sah das dann ganz anders aus
nämlich gesagt als die hochgefahren im
harz ordentlich gewinne da waren
wirklich orkanartige böen dabei da gaben
teilweise auch ein kräftiger
regenschauer die hier über platz gefegt
sind und das fordern mit dem wind gehen
partnern so dass mir das waagerecht ins
gesicht ging das war jetzt nicht
wirklich so schön aber letztendlich ist
es erst mal so sagen die harzer auf
jeden fall werden mit einigen gesprochen
ja ein ganz normaler herbststurm davon
haben wir 20 bis 30 im jahr pi mal
daumen es gab auch keine wirklich großen
einschränkungen verkehr die eine oder
andere straße hier war da mal gesperrt
weil dann sind dann irgendwie bäume
abgebrochene äste abgebrochen ein baum
der hat sogar einen autofahrer getroffen
dem ist aber nichts passiert er ist
unverletzt geblieben also es gab da um
ganz bisschen probleme im verkehr aber
im großen und ganzen was die harzregion
anbelangt war das relativ übersichtlich
niedersachsenweit gesehen wieso der bahn
kollege münchner zehn grad aus nordrhein
westfalen schon gesagt kam es auch
natürlich in niedersachsen so
einschränken aber nicht so großartigen
auch der fährverkehr zu den
ostfriesischen inseln
da sind nicht alle fähren wirklich
gefahren darüber die kleineren flüsse
hat die eine oder andere fähre dann mal
den verkehr kos ausgesetzt aber im
großen und ganzen läuft der verkehr
eigentlich relativ flüssig vielen dank
für deine schilderungen haid weiter
durch bis dahin tschüss
katja es gibt ja auch warnungen vor
einer sturmflut an der nordsee weser und
ems gebiet wie wie ist deine
einschätzung das soll ein meter fünfzig
über dem normalen hochwasser sein dass
das jetzt auch nichts ganz wahnsinnig
überraschendes oder so also bei einer
richtig schweren sturmflut da sprechen
wir dann von drei meter oder noch höher
das heißt die üblichen ufernahe gebiete
werden sicherlich geflutet werden aber
das ist auch dort nichts was die
anwohner und anwohnerinnen nicht schon
kennen würden nichtsdestotrotz das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe hat mehrere tipps
gegeben was bei unwetter zu beachten ist
wir schauen mal dazu zählt etwa zu hause
bleiben fenster und rollläden schließen
empfindliche geräte vom netz nehmen
bewegliche gegenstände im außenbereich
sichern und während des unwetters
möglichst im erdgeschoss aufhalten hat
er wenn man solche ratschläge nennen
hört dann denkt man sich das klingt ja
schon irgendwie bedrohlich sind
vorsichtsmaßnahmen dieser art bei so
einer wetterlage durchaus auch angezeigt
ja natürlich aber jeder hat ja auch
seinen gesunden menschenverstand jeder
hat es ihren gesunden menschenverstand
also wenn wir merken dass draußen
vielleicht dem aufwachen an den rollos
ist rüttelt oder so dann werden wir ja
schon guevara ist jetzt irgendwas
besonderes dann mache ich natürlich
nicht die rollos hoch und schau mal wie
sitzen da außen kraft mit dann
vielleicht gerade der nachbar baum ins
fenster also das heißt mit diesen
gesunden menschenverstand ausgestattet
ist es glaube ich normal dass man mit
dem wetter irgendwie umgeht dass nun
jeder der im dachgeschoss normalerweise
seinem home office nach geht jetzt ins
erdgeschoss geht weil irgendjemand sagt
naja es ist da vielleicht sicherer wenn
drumherum alles nur ein bisschen weg
halte ich das für etwas übertrieben aber
wie gesagt mit dem gesunden
menschenverstand sollten wir da
eigentlich zurechtkommen ok also
gesunder menschenverstand und plus jetzt
noch ein satellitenbild auf dass ich den
draufschauen und wo du uns bitte zeigt
wie sich dieser sturm im laufe des tages
jetzt noch ein blick ja der satelliten
film zeigt uns natürlich eher was
gewesen ist also sieht man ganz gut wie
dieses tiefe entlang gezogen ist von der
nordseeküste jetzt inzwischen weiter zur
ostsee und hat die ostsee bereits
erreicht man sieht ja auch ganz schön wo
der sturm entlang gezogen ist also der
heftigste sturm das heftigste sturmfeld
war das habe ich hier mit dem dreieck
gekennzeichnet das ist immer etwa
südöstlich vom tief druckzentrum da
sieht man jetzt gerade in den nächsten
stunden wird es noch in thüringen auch
in sachsen kräftig wen mit orkanartigen
böen und vielleicht auch noch mal im
bayerischen wald im oberpfälzer wald
aber dann ist das sturmtief wirklich
durch und sie erwarten dann also zum
abend eine wirkliche beruhigung ist doch
eine gute nachricht für alle die jetzt
im bahnverkehr auf irgendwas warten dass
dafür noch fährt dann gibt es vielleicht
noch stürmische böen sturmböen 60 70
kilometer pro stunde aber eben nicht
mehr diese ganz ganz schweren sturmböen
und morgen über marc werden wir zwar in
norddeutschland auch nochmal sturmböen
haben das nicht zu vergleichen mit dem
was wir jetzt hatten also das heißt eine
gute nachricht dass sich das jetzt alles
abflaut auch der deutsche wetterdienst
der wand unglaube maximal in sachsen
noch bis 15 uhr mit unwetterwarnung vor
orkanartigen böen okay das heißt die
nächsten tage werden sehr viel ruhiger
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen
herbstlich schöner das können wir
genauso sagen also der wind dreht jetzt
von südwest auf nordwest und wird es
kälter zunächst mal führt auch dazu dass
nach der kaltfront heute nacht ist in
der eifel oder so tatsächlich auch frost
geben könnte also wird es richtig kalt
in den nächsten tagen liegen die
temperaturen um zehn grad wahrscheinlich
wird es zum anfang der kommenden woche
aber schon wieder ein bisschen milder
werden und die gute nachricht ist dass
das wochenende uns wirklich schönes
wetter bringt also schön damit meine ich
sonne und wolken im wechsel vielleicht
hier und da auch mal wieder nebelfelder
die sich länger halten können aber
richtig ruhiges wetter das so ein
bisschen entschädigt für diesen doch
sehr stürmischen donnerstag dann wollen
wir diesen stream mit diesem wunderbaren
ausblick beschließen vielen dank katja
dass sie zu uns ins studio gekommen bist
und auch in vielen dank fürs dabeisein
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
nachmittag idealerweise heute drin man
sich gut
[Musik]